[Music]
welcome everyone to today's long now
talk it's a three-way conversation it's
going to be me stuart brand i'm the
president of the long now foundation
and
please welcome also from along now kevin
kelly
who is known as the senior maverick at
wired but he's also co-chair of the long
now foundation
thank you stuart
glad you're here joining us today is
jonathan height
he's a social psychologist at new york
university
and i'm going to mention just two titles
of the works that he's done one is a
book
from a couple years ago called the
righteous mind
why good people are divided by politics
and religion
and then this year we
got stimulated to invite him to one of
these occasions
by the title and then content of a
piece he wrote for the atlantic title
why the past 10 years of american life
have been uniquely stupid
and then the subtitle which he may or
may not have provided but he can explain
is it's not just a phase
why is it not just a face and and what
made it so stupid
thanks so much stuart and kevin what a
pleasure to be talking with you both um
so um i'm a social psychologist and i
study morality in my work i try to take
a really long perspective i often try to
start with what made humans unique
beginning one or two million years ago
when we became cultural creatures
so i love taking this very long
perspective on humanity and seeing that
we evolve to be tribal religious
creatures we do we have animistic gods
we dance around campfires we move in
synchrony this is human nature and over
time we've developed institutions that
allow us to live in the modern world
incredibly peacefully and we've had so
much progress of the sort that the two
of you have written about and steve
pinker writes about so i'm with you on
all of that that background that
perspective on on humanity and an
extraordinary upward our ascent into
prosperity and peace and health
and rights and equality
until about 2014 2015.
so i i'm a professor i teach on campus
and
weird stuff started happening in 2014
we saw students suddenly objecting to
words and books and speakers uh we saw
them uh bringing in ideas that words are
violent so all this strange stuff was
happening we thought it was just
something about college students my
friend greg lukianov and i wrote an
article about this called the coddling
of the american mind in the atlantic in
2015.
uh it came out in august and then in
october november of that year many
universities kind of blew up and and
this new culture came in and it's a
culture that
could not have happened without twitter
and other platforms it's a culture of
fear and attack
and this is completely incompatible with
academic life we we have to be able to
talk
question each other challenge ideas we
have to do that or there's no point in
coming to work and all of a sudden
anything you say you could be called out
for uh if if you question received
wisdom you will there could be literally
a movement to get you fired
and so academic life changed in 2015 in
a very qualitative way
but we still thought that it was just
something weird about universities
and i was puzzling over this and
puzzling what the hell happened to us
and then it began to happen in
journalism and in the arts talk to any
museum director anywhere in america
um
in
media
and in many parts of tech and a lot of
it has to do with areas where there's
very little political diversity when
almost everybody's on one side you get
these dynamics i don't want to go too
deep into the story now but that's what
the article is about it's about what
happens when tech
what social media we're talking about
allows everyone to intimidate everybody
to attack or or ruin the reputation with
no accountability no need for evidence
no nuance no context i've spoken to a
lot of people who've been canceled um
and it is terrifying social death is
what the ancients used to use you know
if you're guilty either we kill you or
we exile you and make you socially dead
and moderate people are not prepared for
it so
um it's really this is my main choice
that
social media in particular and here i
especially mean a few business models
that are about optimizing for engagement
so especially twitter to a lesser extent
you know facebook tip top we'll see
that's going to that's probably going to
play a bigger role later
so that's what i'm talking about and
it's changed the institutions
well it's interesting
um
my sense is that you're a liberal john
is that true
well oh my god i am a liberal in the not
i was always a liberal in the sense of
on the left and i've always been a
democrat but what's happening to us now
is
um is we're in a polarization spiral
where the right
i've been focused on the left so far
because that's what's affecting
universities but a parallel process
happening on the right so the right is
no longer conservative we have the
extreme far right we have a maga
movement that has no connection to
edmund burke or the wisdom of
conservatism we have a far right which
is increasingly prone to violence and
militias uh and that's driven by uh as
well by social media uh uh uh changing
the media ecology in which they operate
and the things they believe
um and we have a left which is moving
further to the left um and becoming
increasingly illiberal so the right is
not conservative the left is not liberal
but i'm a liberal in the sense of
liberal democracy i believe
the best kind of life for human beings
is one in which we have rule of law uh
due process freedom of speech so the
world that i grew up in the late 20th
century was making extraordinary
progress towards i would almost say a
liberal utopia or at least let me just
say a good liberal society until about
2014 and then it all ran off the rails
so i have a question john um you
describe this mechanism where the um
compounding amplification of uh
this you know dissatisfaction whatever
would cause this um cancellation and
people becoming timid
um why don't we see that on the right
because they're using the same
technology oh well so okay so this is
there
we do but there's an asymmetry and this
was a subtle point in my atlantic
article but it's one which i think is
very very helpful in our present moment
especially as we come towards the
midterms so what i argued in the article
is that of the two major political
parties in the united states the
republican party is the stupid party and
what i mean by that is not that they're
unintelligent but that their dynamics
are such that if you
if you question donald trump if you say
that oh you know i'm going to vote for
impeachment um you're dead you're
politically dead uh and you know as liz
chaney found out is everybody everybody
just about who challenged donald trump
is dead um
uh
you know
electoral so you're saying they were
cancelled is what you were saying that's
right so so the republican party is the
stupid party because it does not have
the normal dynamics of some people say
we should do this but other people say
we shouldn't do this that's normal they
don't have that anymore that's
incredibly dangerous to have a two-party
system where one party is stupid and
unable to think is incredibly dangerous
okay and people including these say now
look at the democrats it's not like that
the democrats have awoke wing but who
wins the debates it's almost always the
moderates so the democratic party is not
the stupid party and people on the left
keep attacking me or you know just
criticizing me saying how can you say
you know look at the republicans look
what they're doing and i say you know
you're right you're right that is the
stupid part of the democrats are not the
stupid parties so you're not you're not
okay sorry go ahead kevin
i have yeah get the other side in
otherwise this clip will be excised and
they'll say height said the republican
party is stupid no let me finish i have
to finish because now put yourself not
looking at the parties put yourself in
the perspective of a citizen a citizen
on the right or a citizen on the left
and if you're a citizen on the right
what do you see happening
you see
uh just insane stuff happening to your
children because of the cultural left
you see school closures driven by what
by the teachers union by
bizarre claims that are just not
relevant to children
you see the san francisco of course is
the poster child
the schools are closed but boy they're
going to rename everything that was
named after abe lincoln and it doesn't
even matter that the argument was
historically inaccurate had nothing to
do you know so the the arguments are
stupid they make no sense but no one
dares challenge them so the let me just
stay with the with the republican angle
for a minute
um
[Music]
i've been watching the process i'm sure
you have two since 1994 when newt
gingrich
sat in motion a
republican representative approach uh
that
tried to keep people out of town living
with their families where they came from
so they wouldn't uh become friendly with
democrats that set in motion the idea
that no democratic president was going
to have a successful administration
and that anybody who was
in any way a moderate would be expunged
from the party
so
that started
20 years before
2014
and the process was far along and it
sounds like you're saying the process
then
went even further because of what social
media started doing in 2014 is that
right
yes but let me put a little nuance in
there so first if we look at
polarization at affective polarization
the degree to which people on each side
hate or fear the other side
that was pretty level in the 70s 80s and
90s and it only begins to go up in the
late 90s in part because of the kinds of
events you're talking about the
republican party begins to radicalize
now here fox news plays a big role um
and the move from broadcasting and this
is crucial for what's going to come
broadcasting was a temporary period of
american history where we had a message
beamed out to hundreds of millions of
people and we all got the same
information that was a temporary few
decades and that gave incredible
centripetal force that was a real
binding factor in the country
so cable tv begins to undo that begin to
fragment and fox news begins in 1996 or
something like that and then they get
more and more partisan they discover
that that's what sells so it is true
that for polarization a big part of the
blame goes to cable tv which radicalized
the right it did not radicalize the left
also happened in the radio that the
right got more radicalized in the last
that's not so much yeah that's right
that's right so so those offline the
radio and tv that was mastered by
republicans the democrats or the left
tribe they never really air america
never really took off but then the left
colonized late-night comedy like jon
stewart but okay so that's the older
media ecosystem
but it's not just a one-dimensional like
how how strong is polarization what
happened i argue after uh around 2014
what happened around then wasn't just oh
now we hate each other more because of
twitter it's not that it's
um two things one is
we're now afraid of each other
fox news did not make me afraid of my
students
um twitter does
uh most of them are lovely but if i say
anything any one of them can publicize
it they can report me so um twitter has
social media in general uh and
and slack also these have a unique
quality it's not just increasing
polarization it's fragmenting and making
people afraid of each other
another difference is that people's
people say
facebook wrote a response to me and i
wrote a response to them and they said
but you said well you know isn't cable
tv isn't that what caused most of this
well what happened to cable tv once uh
facebook took all of the um facebook and
twitter got all of the you know the ad
revenue um everyone had all of the
networks have to now coordinate they
they sync up with social media and if
you look at any right wing talk show now
they have an incredible lab that finds
them the most outrageous story of the
day
every day and it's just whatever's
trending on twitter so so
social media has made mainstream media
much more toxic much more nasty much
better at making people angry so um
so far the conversation has been very
u.s centric and
together the two other largest countries
in the world china and india combined
have 10 times
the population of the u.s us and
increasingly um
ten times the influence
so are you seeing the same kinds of
things happening
in india and
china brazil
indonesia all the other large countries
of the world yeah
and that would be for me
almost a more persuasive um case
yeah so let's distinguish between
democracies and autocracies uh and this
is a point made by by tristan harris
that um that the technology
is helping autocracies be better
autocracies and by that i mean more
effective so china is able to control
what happens they have tip talk in china
but it's got it's got much more positive
stuff it sort of boosts patriotism and
they're thrilled that our tick tock is
just making people so angry at each
other and so mentally ill
so
so china is the example of using
technology to achieve a totalitarian
dream
the soviet union and mao's china they
just didn't have the technology to
really control everybody all the time
other than just brute fear what i can
tell you about europe um is and this is
from the revelations from francis haugen
is when facebook changed its algorithm i
think it was to
i forget it was the one to get more
meaningful social engagement they
changed the algorithm and all of a
sudden european political parties found
that their normal messages didn't go
anywhere unless they made them more
outrageous and angry and they said to
facebook hey what have you done what
have you done we have to be more
polarizing and we'd be not angry so
facebook can turn things up and down and
and we do have a direct uh direct effect
i should also say that i'm curating i
have a google document if you go to
jonathan.com
social media i have google documents
where i put all of the published
academic articles that we can find on
democracy and on teen mental health
my kids grew up without tv and but on
the internet
and um they've retreated from social
media
do you find
that happening worldwide is is that in
other words because the outrage because
of the fact that outrage seems to be the
single
emotional tone
that people just get tired of and decide
um
you know i don't really want it anymore
um do you do you find that happening
around the world in any degree so yeah
so first let's distinguish there's two
separate problems one is teen mental
health which we haven't talked about and
that's not caused by outrage that's
caused by girls going through puberty
posting photos of themselves for
strangers to rate and comment on that's
a that's a major major issue
um and and there is clear signs that you
know kids they do move on from platform
to platform they were on facebook long
ago and then to instagram and now tick
tock so kids do move around but there's
no sign of the mental health crisis
abating in fact it just keeps going up
and up and up kovid made things worse
but it was a trend that was already
unbelievable before quoted and that's
worldwide too as well
so i have good data i can show that it's
happening in all the english-speaking
countries i know that um and there's
some uh it's not clear it's happening in
the germanic countries that there's
reasons for that they they let their
kids outside to play they let them
explore in the english countries we all
freaked out in the 90s and said oh my
god i can't let me kid out my 10 year
old he'll be kidnapped so we have we've
made our kids weak gen z we made them
very we over protected them over
supervise them and then that same
generation uh went through they're the
first ones to go through puberty on
instagram that never that um there's
evidence that that really is harmful so
that's the kids issue on the democracy
issue
um there um i don't know about people
changing around you know adults are
mostly on facebook
twitter a few other platforms that are
extremely important for politics um it
is still the case i mean the um you'll
find in the google document um there's
there's there is research on how various
countries the political actors the the
the leaders use social media to weaken
or or discredit their political
opponents um so that's all part of the
political process and you know
there there should be ways in which this
technology will get give us better
democracy someday but for now it does
appear to be giving us worse democracy
so where did this thing about
triggers and trigger warning come from
is that
part of all this
uh yeah so that's back to the teen
mental health thing back on the teen
mental health thing so um
there are id so there are multiple ways
of looking at
human beings and
that's fine that's great but there's a
particular way that sort of comes out of
out of certain political movements that
were housed especially in a few
departments gender studies uh various
humanities areas but especially a few of
the studies departments
and those go back to the 1980s they were
philosophical movements arguments fine
they're welcome at a university but
they try they
they get students to see the world as
divided into oppressors and oppressed
and anybody who's got high stage
privilege is bad they're evil and anyone
who's got low status is good they're the
victims and and it makes it valorous to
be a victim
and what we're finding for a lot of for
girls is
because you get status from being a
victim girls are encouraged to emphasize
their anxiety disorders their depression
their mental illness and so if mental
illness becomes valorized now everyone's
fragile
i can be a good person by looking up for
you
if the professor says a word or signs a
book that i think could upset you then
i'm going to report the professor so
there's no evidence that trigger
warnings are helpful well
sometimes these things just sort of pass
away
um
and the
odd notions go through that
everybody turns out to have been abused
as a child and all these satanic things
that were done to them and and then they
confess these things and have what
turned out to be completely
false memories and that yeah that
that uh tortured us all for a couple of
years and then it went away
um
what's mental illness is not like that
this is not a set of factual beliefs
this is we've had um if you look at
young girls in particular it's between
50 to 150 increase
uh in depression anxiety self-harm and
suicide gen z is extremely fragile um
and now the oldest of them are 26 and
it's not as though they're suddenly
gonna say oh well i'm not i'm gonna
outgrow that um if you go through
puberty
with on social media platforms and you
and you don't develop normal social
skills your brain wires up differently
than the normal evolutionary plan for
human beings and it's possible that the
damage will be permanent
so you've been a defender of free range
childhood what's that about
humanity has this funny thing called um
called the uh slow childhood we
other animals just grow as fast as they
can and they reproduce
we grow fast for a couple years and then
we actually slow down our brain is 90
done by the time we're five at least in
terms of size and we slow down we have a
long period of cultural apprenticeship
because we're cultural creatures so
during that period kids need to learn
learn learn and how do they learn from
play play play that's the way mammals
learn so kids have to be outside playing
um with each other
and then we stop that in the 90s kids
used to play i grew up during the crime
wave stuart maybe you grew up before the
crime wave but you know there was a lot
of crime in the
from the
mid 60s through the early 90s but kids
went out to play
suddenly when the crime wave ended in
the 90s just by coincidence that's when
americans freaked out about child
abduction and we stopped letting kids
out we literally said you know i mean by
you know in 2006 we hear the first cases
of people being arrested because their
kids were caught playing in a park
because by 2006 nobody had seen a child
outside unsupervised in 10 years
so once we did that to kids where they
were weakened kids need to be outside
playing that's how you learn the skills
of democracy
what game should we play well let's how
do we figure out whose preferences how
do we enforce the rules well this was an
infraction but it was an accident like
so kids need to do that thousands and
thousands of times
that doesn't happen on video games that
doesn't happen on instagram so we've
basically given our kids what you might
call uh experience blockers uh once they
get on a phone they're all on it all the
time the boys are on video games which
are not as bad the girls are on the
visual platforms which are really bad
and childhood is partly over the free
play is over um and so i co-founded an
organization with lenore skines you
called let grow if you go to litgrow.org
and we've gotten laws changed in four
states there are four states now where
you can't be arrested just because your
kid plays in a park
well well
once upon a time i did a thing called
the new games tournament where i try to
get adults to do what kids do which is
change the rules of the game
that they're playing all the time
uh you know they're
we played baseball vacant lot next to my
house and it wasn't big enough for three
bases so we had two
beautiful i'd come play
and um you know we had to keep changing
the rules on uh what was a home run
depending on who was at bat and things
like that
and the changing rules i thought uh in
this kind of free range mode
is actually a very civilizing thing to
do that's right and maybe that's
curtailed by little league and um you
know kid lacrosse and soccer moms and
all this thing exactly that's exactly it
that's right let's remember when we say
the american experiment people forget
what that means it is the american
experiment in self-governance that's the
experiment that our founders set out on
and it wasn't clear that we would
succeed can people govern themselves
without a king that's the question and
for a long time the answer was yes
how about the far right wing the guys
who are liking guns and all this stuff
were they not free-range children
oh no they they i i don't know anything
about their childhoods um there is
actually a big left-right difference the
left is much more overprotective of its
children so um the right is much
stronger than the left uh and this is
something van jones noted in his talking
in pharmacy
that strong meaning what just physically
strong no emotionally strong that um
that the left has adopted a set of
beliefs and practices that are crippling
its kids and so when van jones gave a
talk at the university of chicago and
david axelrod asked him about you know
protesting speakers and and he said no
stop doing that and he directly
addressed the left-leaning students at
the university of chicago and he said i
don't want you to be safe ideologically
i don't want you to be safe emotionally
i want you to be strong
and what we're seeing is that students
are asking for these protections to
guarantee that they do not become strong
and this is what we're seeing left-wing
organizations there was an article in
um what was it called and what magazine
was it it was an article called the
elephant in the zoom
in the intercept magazine it was about
how progressive uh activist
organizations are all
collapsing into constant micro battles
because gen z is so easily harmed and
angered it's very difficult to work with
them it's very difficult for left-wing
groups now to actually be effective
that's not happening on the right
they've got different problems they've
got militias they are a real threat to
democracy
but they don't have the the quite the
overprotection coddling weakness
problems that the left does you
mentioned earlier um video games and
particularly boys
video games themselves
the businesses would like to become more
of a social media in fact that's
happening already with discord when
people are playing other people around
the world in
uh friends of friends and etc do you see
similar kinds of things happening with
or do you see a similar danger i should
say with video games particularly the
modern um multiplayer video games yeah
in moderation no um if if boy so you
know so the research shows very clearly
boys went right for video games and
youtube that's what the boys mostly do
the girls do the visual platforms um
if you know if if boys are playing two
three hours a day no problem at all um
for a couple of reasons one is that it's
synchronous synchronous is is good kids
need lots of synchronous activity um
asynchronous is bad um secondly it is
play it is actual play whereas posting
on instagram is not play um so my son uh
when he was uh 13
i finally relented and let him get
fortnight just before kobet thank god i
did because he had no other social life
and he was you know you could hear him
yelling and screaming and laughing and
it is play and it is communal and it's t
you know it's boys want to practice team
versus team competition to prepare for
war that's what play that's what boys
play is aimed at a lot of it so video
games in moderation i have no problem
with um now they're very addictive and
when you get kids who are doing eight
hours a day now they're blocking out all
other experiences boys mental health is
also really bad i should be clear boys
mental health has has gotten much worse
since the early 2010s as well but i
cannot link it to social media or to
electronics directly there's correlation
overall but i don't have i've not found
studies that show
problems for video games whereas for
social media and girls it's it's it's
very clear even
even the people who publish studies
claiming to say that there's not a
relationship if you read their paper you
say oh actually it always turns out to
be a correlation of around point one to
point one five there are correlations
and they're not tiny
so um
i don't know if we can solve this but
one one of the um
you began by saying that you
like to think about the long-term
effects of things like to think of a
long-term perspective
if we take this condition of the of
social media right now which by the way
it um has only been around for i don't
know maybe seven thousand days in total
it's still an infant
still figuring out what it wants to be
um
and you fast forward you know another 10
or 15 years which is about all that we
can possibly even guess at um
what do you see as some of the possible
scenarios from your point of view
of
let's take
this ignore the the disaster and we all
kill each other and we go back to the
stone age
do you see a possible way that it could
work or be redeemed or or evolved and
what would that entail that's right
that's the key question for us here and
but yeah let's let's shift our focus to
the future here's where i really want to
engage with you guys and actually have
you challenge me because i am incredibly
pessimistic
um about the next 50 years so you know i
was very much on the train of you know
steve pinker matt ridley uh you know
kevin your recent ted talk uh you know
you look at the progress it's incredible
and people have always thought it's
going to hell but actually just gets
better and better
and if we look at material progress
you're right that's definitely true and
it's going to be better and better
my concern is it's actually a metaphor
here is you know if you saw that
terrible show uh don't look up yeah you
know they calculate they calculate that
a meter is gonna you know it's an
asteroid it's gonna hit the earth on
this day
and so i feel like i am a social science
don't look up
no i see there's a sociological asteroid
coming for american democracy others
there's reasons why you know canadian
democracy british democracy not quite as
vulnerable but
you know the asteroid is coming for us
um i think we're gonna have catastrophic
political failure
you can't predict and here i've got my
friend phil tetlock standing over my
shoulder saying john nobody can predict
anything so
but you know if present trends continue
and polarization rises and gen z becomes
ever more fragile and mentally ill and
trust in institutions
you know so i i think we can't keep
going the way we're going for 20 more
years so
something's going to have to change
within the next decade or two i'm also a
big fan of peter turchin who i imagine
is has been talked about on this show uh
peter uh being a russian mathematician
who has books on uh what he calls clio
dynamics or the mathematical study of
history and it was through him that i
learned about ibn kalduna 15 14th
century muslim scholar who wrote about
this cycle where there's actually an
internet meme that captures it
hard times make strong men strong men
make good times good times make weak men
weak men make hard times
so there are cycles to history four
generations typically um after a great
catastrophe people come together and
they create new institutions that
happened after the revolutionary war to
set up our country it happened after the
civil war set up the late 19th century
incredible prosperity uh it happened
after the depression and world war ii
gave us the great post-war american
period
um and peter and several other of these
theorists said
we're due for one
you know 2010 to 2020 in that period
where do for one peter actually
predicted in 2010 that the crisis was
going to hit in 2020. that's what he
pretty he has that in writing in science
magazine in 2010.
so
you know things go up and down i was
raised on the the up part you know you
guys knew a little more of it than i did
i'm 59 now but you know we had this
incredible up here in for american
democracy
incredible progress on you know
civil rights gay rights women's rights
and i mean everything you could care
about if you're progressive incredible
period
um and now we're on the downslope and
our country is more of a laughing stock
and we all have a sense that we're in
trouble
now in part this is inevitable there are
these cycles of history and the post-war
institutions that were created for the
era of mass media
can't work in the area of distributed
everything
so
um we're going to have to go through a
turbulent period there was no even if
social media was never invented we were
gonna go through this okay
so in that sense i i'm not as
pessimistic as i sound because i
understand that like things go up and
things go down uh it could take you know
if it's a normal cycle maybe it'll only
take 20 years 30 years um but if it's
like the printing press which really
took a long time to change things you
know now we're could be talking about a
century or two right so
there could be much better democracy in
our future but we don't know how far in
the future so one of the kind of little
exercises that scenarios like to play is
i'm gonna
be a time traveler i'm gonna come back
from 20 years from now and said tell you
that it all worked out
so how did you think that so what would
you imagine
that would be what
to all work out in 20 years okay great
this is a really that is a great framing
so uh first so we've got to turn off the
spigot on mental illness in kids we've
gotta so i would imagine uh everyone
joined let grow.org they gave them money
we were able to pass more laws we were
able to restore free range childhood so
the generation after gen z grows up
better able to compromise work out the
rules the way stewart did in that
baseball game that that has to happen
because the you know if present trends
continue 100 of people be depressed and
suicidal in a few decades so that's one
that has to happen uh another that i
think would have happened um
some
some major government probably not the
us congress because i don't think it can
do much but maybe it's the uk parliament
somebody
really got a handle on regulating major
platforms and if i say regulation
everyone says oh my god it's content
moderation no it's things like um user
authentication to prevent bots and
russian agents and this and uh
manipulation coordinated attacks so
something has to get a handle to bring
down the virality of of of key social
media platforms it's the verret it's not
the content so much it's the virality
it's the dynamic so something has to
turn it down like with the covet
epidemic we all understand you know if r
naught is five
you know then it's impossible we have to
get it down to like 1.2 you know i mean
small changes make a big difference we
put the morality down that'd be another
thing
another thing would be i think just a
mass movement away from
performative social platforms so a sense
of contempt or shame for people who live
their lives on it so i'm an academic and
i see other academics on twitter get
sucked into it
twitter makes you behave in ways that
are so antithetical to the academic
ethos they make you quick to judge on
little evidence hot takes
um nasty uh so as long as you know as
long as people um are on these platforms
and shaped by them then they're kind of
lost to civilization i would say
and so i think we need a massive kind of
disgusted turning away
i don't know what's called a literacy i
you know it took us four or five years
to learn how to read you may need
to be trained so to speak to use social
media
yeah i don't think that would no i don't
i don't think that would do anything
because so i'm just writing to the part
of my book now where i'm talking about
learning out learning heuristics and i'm
drawing on joe henrich's wonderful work
um on gene culture coevolution and how
we have built into us biases for
learning we have uh conformist bias we
do what most people are doing and we
have prestige bias we do what if
everybody else is pointing to so and so
we'll all copy him too whoever the most
prestigious person is so now it's the
kardashians um so um this is why
but so kids aren't just gonna soak up
what anyone tells them and this is why
you show me a hundred studies on efforts
to teach kids something non-smoking uh
you know sex non-sexual whatever it is
there's a program to teach kids i i
challenge you to show me results from
out you know from a month afterwards
that show any lasting effect kids are
not going to learn just because you
teach them something they're going to
change if the prestigious people are
doing it and so if the cool people
abandon
instagram well for tick tock but if the
cool people abandoned all of it then
there's some hope i would i would put
all my money on social psychological
manipulations rather than on education
so i'm having a
great experience on twitter it's a major
part of the research i'm doing for a
book it's
um
relatively easy with the tools given me
to mute somebody who starts getting
personal or weird
um i haven't had to block anybody 45 000
people paying attention supposedly but
um so there's enough enough of a traffic
it's easy to sort of
keep steerage way to keep it
sane and productive for me and for the
others paying attention
likewise on youtube i understand there's
uh
pathological parts of youtube but uh
kevin kelly and i pay attention to the
how-to youtubes and they are brilliant
they are changing humanity in the most
positive way possible everybody is
capable of learning how to do absolutely
everything i agree no it is incredible
yeah
yeah no thank you for that i actually
know what i make a note to myself before
i start an interview uh remember to be
nuanced and then i often forget until
i'm reminded as you just did
so let's let's be clear the technology
is incredible and most of the things
it's given us are incredible and
wikipedia and youtube these are
unbelievable things for democratizing
knowledge and all over the world so
i'm not a luddite i love the technology
i rely on it myself and twitter i agree
there's a lot of good things about
twitter too
so
i guess what i'm getting at is uh when i
was a kid in the 50s and then into the
60s advertising was the big
uh bugbear
and vance packer did a book the hidden
persuaders and there was all this idea
that uh
there was subliminal advertising going
on they would show you an innocent
seeming video and there were little uh
invisible shots inside it that would
make you buy a rice krispies or
something
my father was an advertising man as it
happened local in rockford illinois
and he said well that can't work he's
mit engineer he must have been right
but everybody was afraid and worried
about that and we tried to protect
children from
advertising because they were going to
um you know
be distorted by it and so on
and then by and by you've got
sorted out and one could probably figure
out a history of how long it took for
that not to frighten people so much
anymore it went from
a threat to a nuisance and we can manage
nuisances
so
um just as kevin and i learned how to be
on social media way back in
uh the late 80s with the well
uh where i got flamed right off of the
well i quit uh because i was on the
receiving end of the everybody starts
not everybody's but enough people's
darts where i felt uh stabbed and
didn't want to live there anymore and i
left
and
i despaired of the medium
and we did not have a true anonymity we
had a sort of pseudo anonymity where you
could have a handle
and so i'm
increasingly in favor of basically no
anonymity except under very certain
circumstances it sounds like you're in
that direction too
well so i think that's the right way to
think about it about what are parameter
changes that would end up changing the
complex dynamical system and i think
it's part of the difficulty here is that
we're good at thinking about mechanical
systems but we're talking about is
really a complex dynamical system where
you can't just like fix a gear you have
to change parameters and then those will
feed back to like change the landscape
and so uh i do understand there are
arguments for uh for allowing people to
be to not use the real name um
i i would like to see certain platforms
will emerge and have emerged like like
linkedin where you have to use your real
name but as long as we're gonna let
people not use the real name i think the
important thing is that they be
authenticated as a person what i mean by
that is right now
um anyone can open any account as many
as they want on the major platforms um i
had a conversation with mark zuckerberg
he to his credit he reached out to a
bunch of people who were you know
critics i think it was back in 2019 and
just before my meeting with him i
created a fake account for my daughter
who was 11 at the time i just lied about
her age i'd use her name i just can i
create an account
by lying yeah very easy to create an
account on facebook and instagram
um and so uh you know right now um you
know kids can go anywhere pornhub
wherever they want you know we're so
careful in the physical world but
online you know buy guns heroin or not
whatever you want
so what we need to do i think we we do
need um some sort of authentication just
that you're a person you're in a country
and you're over 18 and then we have
provisions for when people under 18 can
get on
one of the things that we do is right
now there's a very small number of
people they're almost all men there's
research on trolls a troll is almost
always a man who enjoys
harassing people being an [ __ ] um
very small number of men but one troll
can ruin thousands of people's day
and trolls especially are nasty to women
and black people and so if we care about
people's experience online we would try
to cut down on trolls yeah then facebook
twitter you know sure you know
eventually if you're trying to kill
someone eventually they'll close your
account you just open 10 more accounts
so
um so that has to stop um and if we did
a few things like that then suddenly
twitter again that would bring down the
dynamics the average user of twitter is
perfectly reasonable but the extremes
have a hundred times more influence than
they ever could have before twitter
and that seems to be uh if i'm not
mistaken kind of your general theme is
is that you have these kind of fringe
cases that
have
polluted or distorted the entire effects
and what we need to do is have some way
to
to manage that or to
reintroduce the kind of controls that we
had in normal society to deal with
people who are on the extreme and
um i guess i'm a very s
centric person
and i think that um
those uh solutions will also come in the
form of another technology
um i hope so and they are they are they
are kind of social inventions and so
there's a social component but i think
we can figure out if we know what it is
we want to do how we could maybe
civilize the extremes so that they don't
completely um
pollute the entire middle
let's get kevin a little further on this
now okay sure yeah
kevin kevin's secret sauce these years
is artificial intelligence so yeah yeah
are you gonna
drool a little ai onto this and fix the
problem kevin well i'm not going to uh
everyone else's is happening right now
as we speak and um
yeah um
and are you happy or unhappy about it i
i am happy but but i i recognize the
fact that um ai because it is going to
be the most powerful
technology in our lives will also be
powerfully abused that is that is the
rule it's it's it's going to be
it's going to make the most powerful new
problems that we have and some of those
will be the fact that it can be misused
and so we will have to figure out how
how to do that and there's people
thinking about ai safety and ai
alignment and they're all good i'm glad
they're there um
but um this issue of like um
going back to the bots i'm 100 percent
with you john that we should have true
names only
uh people um who are speaking as humans
should be really human um but that
doesn't and and we shouldn't be um
mixing or we should be confused by um
things that are being generated by ai
but lots of times this is going to be a
partnership and that's that's where it's
going to get really hard to kind of
vanish because
looking at say ai generating art
most of the really good artists are
going to be using ais as tools and these
will be partnerships and so unraveling
that degree is going to be
very very difficult for us as a society
to do it we'll have to invent new tools
to do it but um in general i think i i
don't i'm not saying that i think ai is
a solution to the social media problem i
i didn't say that
i i think that um
other basic things like we just talked
about like
demanding that people be true names and
verifiable i mean even in twitter i
would like to have a function where um
i would only be able to see and retweet
blue check marked real people yeah real
people that's right they'll be huge
yeah great these are the sorts of
architectural changes that i think are
important i've got another one for you
because you know your question was you
know will this will the technology help
us or will it save us quite possibly so
i've just gotten involved recently with
what's called project liberty if you go
to project liberty dot io uh it's an
initiative uh started by frank mccourt
uh who founded the the mccourt school
the georgetown
and it's a proposal for an architect a
web 3 based architecture on which people
could build applications and businesses
where it would be sort of automatic that
people can control
what they give out people retain
ownership of
of their own information
with current with web 2
once the information is out you can't
get it back
but there i'm just beginning to learn
about this but i think this is the sort
of innovation the sort of
of
like
not just like what are we going to
change in twitter but what could we
change in the underlying architecture of
the entire technium
so that it's easy to build
applications that are healthy and good
for democracy and it's harder to build
exploitative manipulative ones
so you know look silicon valley is
incredibly smart tech people are
incredibly smart and now they do tend
towards asperger's and autism and this
is important it's not just this is not
an insult this is just a fact about
different minds having different talents
and so the kinds of minds that were so
brilliant in creating these tools
are also the kinds of minds that are
least likely to understand the nuances
of social interaction and the
difficulties that their products are
causing for social interaction
so i think we need neurodiversity in
silicon valley uh but but ultimately yes
there is real hope that um that that
tech suitably you know enmeshed in teams
of people and and
and and political diversity and
neurodiversity really could come up with
game-changing architectures that
bring us to this this promised land i'm
with you guys that that the tech could
in theory give us the best societies
ever the best democracies ever that
could happen it could it's not gonna
happen in the 20 in the 2020s but it
maybe it'll happen 2030s maybe it won't
be till the 2090s i don't know it it's
in theory possible and then our
challenge and it's actually i know i'm
very pessimistic but when i try to end
talks on an optimistic note what i find
myself saying is
um
we have a chance to matter like the
things that we do the decisions we make
the choices we make and how we use
technology and where we invest our money
and how we treat people the choices we
make now can have more of an influence
on the future than i would say at any
point since maybe the 1930s or early
1940s this is a turning point in history
it's actually very exciting it's
frightening but it's also very exciting
and if you agree with that kevin
absolutely
absolutely i think this is a turning
point in history yes i think i think
this is i mean we have the convergence
of all these um what you know robert um
robert gordon would say
once in a lifetime once in the planet's
uh histories we have we have these
headwinds or tailwinds of um
a.i
ubiquitous ai ubiquitous universal
connection where we're for the first
time we have
like easily for the first time ever
connected together we have the
um urbanization the almost a total
urbanization of the planet which is
really great news for so many things
and um
we have these accelerants uh going all
over the youtube of learning and
disseminating science and so
um and we have other
um ones we have one challenge which in
the long term is the population
implosion but other than that i think
that that this moment will be
looked back on as an amazing time to be
alive because it's really just the
beginning of all these things and so um
i 100 that our decisions make a huge
difference and that's
one of the things i would say you know i
wrote the book the inevitable what's
inevitable are some of these things
coming along what's not inevitable is
the character of them who owns them how
they're controlled
how they're regulated
what role they play those are choices
that we have and they make a huge
difference and so i'm totally with you
john on
this moment trying to
make the best of it right now for the
next generation let me
let me put the problem a little
differently to you john
what if it's turning points from here on
in
yeah that's the uh that's a possibility
and and the acceleration uh keeps
re-impacting itself
uh humanity
does actually collectively figure out
how to either manage or live with
climate change
um
and civilization just keeps cranking on
it doesn't slow down there's parts that
slow down like north korea like spain
once did but most of it just is
increasingly global and increasingly
increasing
uh
what's
what is the mode
to
negotiate
and find a way to live
that way collectively if any
so that's what my book uh the book i'm
writing now is about the title of the
book is life after babel adapting to a
world we
we may never again share
and so what if it's not like cycles
where there will you know what if it's
like this
and and it just keeps getting faster and
faster and and i guess that's the
singularity
one of the features of this speeding up
is that we can't share stories anymore
there is no one there's no common
understanding
when 9 11 happened there was a general
understanding that we were attacked by
al-qaeda
and that's probably the last time that
that will happen
we can't
with the current technologies everything
is shredded social media is good at
creating little micro bubbles of meaning
but we'll never again or not never again
in in the next five or ten years we're
not going to have any ability to have
shared stories and if you tell me that
well what if it's this
i would say that we would be
so far surpassing the speed limit on
human sociality um we
we can't adapt to change that fast now
there's personality differences
progressives like more change
conservatives like slower change uh
that's the wisdom of edmund burke and i
actually think edmund burke is something
everybody should read today
so
we might say that oh you know progress
let's go faster and faster but i think
the conservatives are right that social
order is very hard to build very easy to
destroy and right now we're destroying
it right left and center
there is very little respect for
institutions for democratic institutions
epistemic institutions journalism
science
so if you tell me what if it's just
going to keep going faster and faster i
would say
well now we're it's you know it's like
what if we've gone over niagara falls
and there's no bottom it's just falling
faster and faster in you know how you
know how water comes over then it
divides up into droplets
what is older droplets moving faster
forever and ever and that's it
that is a vision of hell um for emil
durkheim my favorite sociologist that is
anomie or normlessness
just constant change no community no
ability to even understand what we're
doing that's that's the metaphor of
babel
so so um there's a couple of things one
is you know i spent
until kovit i spent an awful lot of my
time outside the us
and um
the constant question i asked about is
um what's
diverging what's converging
are we really splintering up into these
timeless stick little tiny this mist
which is a wonderful view just yeah it's
missed good i like it um
and i i kind of concluded that there was
uh almost like uh
a you know the um hypothetical math loss
hierarchy this pyramid which he actually
didn't draw but we all blame on him
that there was a almost a total
convergence at the bottom
of the pyramid in terms of everybody in
the world every young person that i
could see wanted to live in a
air-conditioned box with indoor plumbing
and wi-fi wi-fi being the most essential
and we were wearing sneakers and
t-shirts i mean it was like and they
were studying exactly the same things in
school the curriculum
was exactly the same it was a universal
so there was this convergence at the
lower levels of
shelter clothing and those needs but i
felt that there was kind of a divergence
at the top about what it means about the
meaning thing right what we think our
purpose is what we imagine that we're
doing um our the name of our
job that there was this divergence there
and so um i so
that's good news and bad news one is
this is that we're inventing new things
to do they're great i think the
challenge which you have brought up is
that there's not a shared story that's
right and particularly as we go global
because i think again i'm always
thinking in terms of global um is this
happening globally is is are we
diverting where there's not a shared
story globally
and yeah that's that may be the case
yeah so here i'd like to bring up john
lennon's song imagine which is an anthem
for the left it's a beautiful song it
moves me to tears but it asks us to
imagine
that there's no nations no countries
just everybody living in peace no
private property
and it sounds good to people on the left
but it's again it's a vision of hell to
people on the right i think the right is
actually more accurate here and for this
reason i mean it's complicated but what
i mean is um
we just as bees have to live in hives
they can't live independently
we are hive creatures too we have to
have webs of shared meaning
and could we have well fine why don't we
just have a big global web of shared
meaning why don't we all be together as
one that can't work that can't work
because
how do we cooperate we cooperate with
death when we're competing
that's what brings people together and
that's what created those periods of
enormous social capital and progress was
the wars revolutionary war civil war and
world war ii
um and our human nature is to divide up
into groups to compete with each other
now our civilizing intuitions channel
that competition into sports and
politics those are great and it's now
it's running off the rails it's it's
it's
you know it's spilling over and we'll
soon i think we're going to have a lot
more political violence we're getting
some now um but i think it's going to be
much more like the 60s and early 70s
with a lot more political violence
coming first perhaps from the right
which has organized militias that are
called accelerationists they actually
want to bring out the collapse but we
may if the right takes control of the
government we are going to see political
violence coming from the left as well
i just want to read a quote from james
madison from federalist 10
who noted
you know of course madison in designing
our institutions our constitution um he
noted that humans are prone to faction
or tribalism and he said
um so strong is this propensity of
mankind to fall into mutual animosities
that were no substantial occasion
presents itself the most frivolous and
fanciful distinctions have been
sufficient to kindle their unfriendly
passions and excite their most violent
conflicts
so if we all converge on having
comfortable
you know bunkers with wi-fi and big
screen everything and you know uh
metaverse and we're all comfortable
we're gonna be fighting all the time
find things to fight about and maybe not
all of us a lot of us want to live in
peace but a lot of people be fighting
all the time over stupid little things
so we can't stop that but we can channel
it into good competition right now we
are unchanneling it's running over the
banks and it's seeping into everything
it's seeping into restaurants doctors
offices it's all over k-12 education and
universities the culture war is eating
us alive i think we need a geneva
convention for the culture war that says
we channel you know you know like you
know they had chemical weapons they
decided you know what this is just too
terrible let's not use chemical weapons
i would say you know what you know
schools our children doctors like let's
not do culture war there let's just you
know insist on professional ethics and
get politics out of those areas
i think it we might be headed towards
just miss mist but like miss bit of the
water droplets fighting each other in
order to totally mix the metaphor
john i think let's end with you and john
and madison uh pointing us in the right
direction
um pointing at the uh strengthening of
institutions and the
and the um being
careful with children
um this is such good stuff and i think
you're on the right track okay well
thank you but you know what i we can't
end with this
bizarre image of water droplets fighting
each other can i end with a quote from
joseph campbell which i think is the
quote for rh
joseph campbell was the this great
mythologist he studied mythology in the
20th century at i was at bryn mawr one
of the liberal arts colleges
and from his study of mythology and of
the hero's journey a lesson he took from
from studying human humanity's tendency
to to put everything in these
big hero stories he said the lesson of
the hero's journey is participate
joyfully in the sorrows of the world we
cannot cure the world of sorrows but we
can choose to live in joy
and then he says the the the worries
approach is to say yes to life
yea
to it all
that's much better than water droplets
fighting okay we're here bringing it
fantastic thank you thank you john it
was really great i so much enjoyed this
conversation
you're here thank you kevin my pleasure
and thank you for stretching me and
helping me think about the long future
the long now
thank you audience for joining us today
tune in next time
[Music]
you